so we have we have Drew Pinsky and we
have my cat dr. drew dr. drew oh we have
to love the old love line boys but also
dr. drew is the CTM pregnant
yes he's the Guru he's the Guru he's
mr16 pregnant which you know I'm a big
fan of and when I bring up sixteen
painting you I want you do suck your
thumb and shut the [ __ ] up now I want to
know I want to just tell the people that
Brennan lied to me to my face oh you
wanna do this well we went to get coffee
and I said I'm gonna hold on it started
because I said did you see that snake
chin bring out my Instagram this man you
see that snake big snake well hold on
its a Diamondback pit viper athletic
yeah pit viper I had a legit Western
diet pathologist that's a lot herpes hey
you all excited and you got excited
about that and you were in an excited
mood and I go what have you seen out
there and you said coyotes he said guys
I seen mountain lion mountain less him
guy I went and you went seen coyotes
mountain lions turned and walked and I
went you have stop for a second I go I
go what you say and you go I said
did you say mountain last and you go yes
I'm my last coyotes it sounds like I go
can we have stopped again now look at me
and if you go you go well and I go
was it a bobcat and he goes might have
been a bobcat I don't know because they
look at you and they run away I go okay
I go so was it a bobcat or did you see a
mountain lion and you go
I didn't say about cam I did see a
coyote though I say you can imagine what
it'd be like so great but I did I did
see a large coyote and it was moving a
thousand mountain lion and I just
included all those animals you pan now I
panic over it will do but I will tell
you this that first of all that is the
biggest most dangerous snake of in my
life is [ __ ] so I'm running right
usually my son was me thank God he
wasn't with me during this okay I'm
running with my I listen to loud music
usually I'm logic right I'm doing my
thing I get my short shorts ass cheeks
out the back of Daddy's moving and I
just for whatever reason I like to vote
my left and I see this gigantic Black
Diamond rattlesnake and I go holy [ __ ]
and I freeze yeah and I take my
headphones off because I'm like it could
just be maybe a gardener it's the
biggest Carter's right so it's not a
brats
either so I think my headphone laughs
and I hear no well that's a rabbit a
California king snake that's around
inside well daddy's just gonna run fast
and because it's two miles get back -
that way
why are you go back this way it's six
miles yeah I don't go back six miles I'm
exhausted third workout of the day sure
so I'm gonna beeline past a snake and
then I got the vision in my head because
I've seen too many snake documentaries
movies of that thing like Hong Kong and
Gideon you know faster Rattlers they're
super fast yeah and I'm not that fast
now
and also I'm in the middle of nowhere
daddy doesn't want to die you're going
down so you know what I did I turned
back around I turned back around with
another six miles he went six miles he
smells Wow I was so scared should have
called me because I would said listen to
me right now hide his face off do a big
u-turn around it and just keep going but
you didn't want it I can't because if
going the shrubs so check this out
problem yeah and there could be another
one inside of one do that I'd be
surrounded and there's mount lines and
there are mountain lions crouched
that'll have it seen but you can imagine
what you can imagine that there there so
you got to choose between mountain lion
and [ __ ] rattles so then it's with by
Whitney's house ago check out the stage
just hold on coming old bands coming
down like you'll be careful there's a
giant ice it Anna conduct as I panicked
so this giant anaconda guess there's
knowing the counts California right my
bat it's a giant black rattlesnake he
goes where so Whitney this old guy
another coffee yeah I lied yeah on
accident I panicked today a mechanic
sure my brain wasn't working
yeah so then I go look I'll show you I
go down el snake he's not there anymore
there's no way hunt a so Dante check
this out we're all staring here I go
yeah he was over here and then go where
is yeah I don't know then I hid behind
this pier and I went see everybody push
the old man down and then [ __ ] pushed
him down I didn't push him down you push
him into the snake I did not actually
get liked it like that's Theo von to
commented that a serpent brother stay
back thanks Captain Obvious series that
steak check this out by myself I went
alright well I'm gonna keep going this
week is shorter path I'm gonna take
these small rocks not gonna hurt them
scare him yeah so I go hey el snaky
you're in my world papa
the thick boys gonna handle this I throw
the rocks they went like this yeah
he there was a person who wanted to kill
it and the old man did enough nothing
the snake did not nothing didn't didn't
flesh badass try giving by see what
happens you fat-ass do not pass go it's
been around since the Java hands no it's
been around like $200 been around since
the Garden of Eden he's the one who
[ __ ] and caused everything to [ __ ] up
in the first place he's the devil he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your stupid
stones I heard an old man somebody was
gonna kill the snake the old man said
you're not gonna kill that soon he would
not let anybody kill that snake because
that snake we're in his home he said you
know nobody's touching that snake I like
that old man yep cuz he's right and he
died today on that mountain he died by
that snake yeah by that snake dude is
that not the biggest [ __ ] live
rattlesnake you've ever seen your life
and he's Negril yeah how crazy is that
that means but how crazy is not that you
don't want that
I was so scared yeah I was sick
sometimes you can get bit in the leg
and what'll happen is the leg no longer
works your leg no longer works your leg
dies happens to dogs all the time oh and
then they eat you alive yeah
I'm telling you I did not much spiders
don't scare me sharks don't happen to me
happen to me I saw a huge loss don't
scare that well I was skid that's more
non-cycling my son yeah I'm scared it
hits your it kind of in a primordial way
do you know that apes are terrified of
snakes so if you have a chimpanzee or a
gorilla and it's around a for any kind
of any kind of simian any kind of his
they see a snake and they scream and run
it's in our DNA that's why they think
human beings have a [ __ ] primordial
fear so your IP less phobia of snakes
they think it's a genetic memory of when
we were can I tell you this because I've
seen so many snake catchers just catch
them and then hold them yeah it crossed
my mind how cool that would be to do for
the gram you gotta get behind it now
that's a pit viper now you don't want
that's such a bad idea
oh it's such a bad idea because if that
thing hasn't bit in a while now
sometimes I don't know if you know this
Brennan but sometimes when a rattlesnake
has just eaten and it injected something
with its venom you might get a dry bite
believe it or not you might get a ghost
load and a large a ghost large
rattlesnake might bite you and give you
only a little venom because I don't want
to lose all there now bait now baby now
oh no why cuz they're just like oh we
have notes we don't have any idea
where's all my values all my venom I
kill they're more dangerous than the
growth that guy sold he might just give
you a dry bite as a warning God don't
don't and you got a little fan out so I
went hiking and my son this morning I
and I sent him this video I said I tell
you we always look out for snakes Papa
he goes I know and he was let's find
that snake oh we're not looking for
snakes so do you see the video I posted
now he didn't give a flying [ __ ] about
any of these snakes and he was
conducting business so listen up turn
this up chin he's on a calculator okay
well dang dude you don't seem too busy
to hike with your dad a lot of deals
going on okay dude sorry man okay I'll
be quite excited dude he's accusing of
all time that is the greatest video
here's my wanna cats I didn't speak out
get some from his mama not me I was the
cutest thing ever fun is that she's
doing business deals dude he didn't give
a flying [ __ ] about the snakes
I kept warning him you do Papa let's
find this thing kill it no really what
are you talking about what I gonna kill
it awesome all right well dr. Drew and
Micah coming in lamb let's see him let's
hang with them all right let's start
this podcast let's get this going right
let's start out let's start with Mike
sounds good hey Brian you know what you
want you want to [ __ ] kick Crone in
the teeth yeah I do do it with on it all
right tell me how well if you could see
like right right now Coronas in the air
yeah I don't go to gyms
I can't attend stairs dad home so give
me a reason
oh maybe I can do the on it online
courses where I get a hundred um outlets
I have a gym I set myself up do you know
where my gyms at where in your heart I
heart
ohana comm slash fighter 10% off on it
six barbell workouts on it six
bodyweight workouts on it six kettlebell
workouts streaming fitness from your
home you want me to see anybody you need
to talk to the riot
it's actually amazing workouts for real
Oh some of them they're like 30 minutes
and they're as good as he can and then
what you do is you do that workout by
yourself you'll feel a little down about
yourself cuz you all alone have nobody
to talk to
then you're going to replenish those
nutrients so you take protein powder not
any protein powder on it protein powder
alright grass-fed New Zealand cows
sweetened with monk fruit so your
[ __ ] insulin doesn't shoot through
the god dude you want your dick
rock-hard I don't know what to do for
you I don't know try some elk bars try
so that might hello team oh you know
what I like to do - when I'm trapped in
my house I like to drink the [ __ ] yeah
coffee which has caffeine crystallized
yeah dude I think crystallizes dude this
there's no word for you that's how good
is this all hopped up on this super
caffeinated coffee bounced off the walls
fantastic calories can we save money go
to on at.com slash fighter for 10% off
you're welcome
we got Mike Catherwood here and Brendan
Schaub of course and both of whom chew
nicotine gum and much to my surprise I
thought what is it it's for kids
these are nicotine pouches patches
pouches pouches pouches pouches pouches
see you but you chew them like gum no no
no no no but a minute ago you look like
you look like dip you all would know
these are super mild I'm afraid of them
these are super mouth oh wait wait wait
so you put the pouch in do you do
nicotine as well well cause of Brennan
bread even though me some and I did it
and I actually felt a little sick I had
like a lot gasps it's a really good
appetite suppressant yes don't want to
eat you never want to eat I once won a
whole day without eating about two weeks
ago and I was like why am I not eating
when I'm not hungry
oh I have nicotine in and it's an
addictive substance but you're saying
it's UNMISS understood because it's not
nicotine that's bad for you it's the
tobacco leaves early oh and also the
additives
tobacco the the plant of tobacco in and
of itself can be looked at as relatively
innocuous it's just like how we put it
in our body
he's pretty harmful you know yeah
so how long you been doin it katene well
if you include smoking and chewing
tobacco I [ __ ] 25 years but I've been
doing just plain nicotine using it as a
drug for its advantages probably like
three years you're an all-or-nothing
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah no I mean I
did Mike got out Mike's body when he got
out of his truck his shoulders are so
broad right as it's gonna be more
shredding with his shirt off no he's
shredded I literally go what kind of
gear are you running right now and he
goes gear are you from Gold's Gym and
yeah build us so I like to hear gear you
said that that's it look at it look at
the body that was this morning dude
you're a much more munches in the yard
yeah yeah I got challenged by like the
guys at UM deuce gym here in Venice yeah
how could you write off yet a lot of it
got a train there my buddy Nick Bauer I
used to train with him well Logan there
he's like doing the walking lunge
Wednesday so Roger Allen 20 minutes just
as many as you can he was so bored go
down farther so that Brian can see my
real dimepiece picture cuz I really want
I want you to I want you to drink that
in and and tell me what you think you're
a body you don't need to be any more cut
than that don't get crazy Mike no don't
look at him there with his family you're
pretty [ __ ] Jack there dude
you're as Jack does you need to be you
don't get better than that don't go
crazy now you understand me oh yeah well
the hurt you you you you I would love to
look like that and I would never work
clothes um I I have had a little bad guy
is that your back that is my bad I
thought those mics if I look at it
that's a very big compliment look at
your back is you know the back is redic
yeah me too
Mike's great there's a lot of like you
know what that is that back is striated
there's a little Christmas tree action
there's a little crazy gotta freeze I
ate it sure you wanted for Brian or is
there a better one there's one one I
wanted to bride to see with that that
I'm actually there we go there we go
that's the Brian I want you to drink
that in and just tell me what you think
that's couple things I want to say
number one I'll never be the same
mm-hmm after that a buzzing yeah yeah
and I'd be although number two I am gay
now I use I thought I was straight
number three um that
might be my my tattoo my one and only
tattoo then I'm gonna get on my teacher
you're like Brad Pitt from Fight Club
that's that's a tremendous compliment
that would be the biggest compliment
except I'm four inches shorter and 700
million dollars poorer got about forty
pounds more muscle in his he was only
about 140 in there yeah that's a big guy
yes oh yeah yeah no more bubble he did a
podcast talking about it
140 yeah he had to have been 170 tiny
you know Mike well he's tiny got real
the thing that Shepard had him Rob
McElhenney on and their time out that's
the best body and Rob was saying I'm
pretty they talked to Brad Pitt
he said we read about that I was so lean
I looked bigger on camera but I was
walking around about 140 Sun high 47 so
that's what people he's got really
really don't understand is that Hmong TV
cameras or of our film camera everything
is all about leanness because you're so
it's you're proportioned to the people
you're standing around so unless you're
filming a movie with the rock it
muscular size yeah doesn't necessarily
matter as much as like leanness because
the presentation is all Brendan would
look like like everybody could fit in
him ya know but but even you notice like
the rock if you look at the rock from
his WWE days to his like a list celeb
he slimmed down a tremendous and got
more shredded because you have to like
Auto fam changes I used to be like in my
first like my first real crack at doing
some TV I was like probably just a year
or two away from my time in bodybuilding
and I was I was [ __ ] diesel but I'd
watch myself back on TV I was like I
just look like a fat guy I know you know
like I just look you just look like a
tree stump you here's your coat on
Instagram enough to this dimepiece pic
you put anybody who knows me or has
listened to me knows that I don't like
to take my shirt off I would only have
my shirt off like that I have suffered
with crippling body image issues I've
been working hard on and now mostly
trained shirtless I know what you might
think you know [ __ ] off your rip so you
don't give don't give me that [ __ ]
about body image issues let's strength
thing about this glitch I'm in good
shape and although I can recognize they
acknowledge that I still felt like my
skin was on fire when I took my shirt
off anyway happy and making progress I'm
proud of the hard work
your your your um your embodying buddy
dysmorphia it's really bad where does
that come from I have it - really bad I
don't know I remember my my psychiatrist
and I've been really working hard on
that because I've kind of you know I'm
not cured or in any way but I kind of
gotten past a lot of the issues I've had
that's one where I don't know where it
came from
you know I'm not like what I do real
quickly I have an idea where that came
from and again it comes from that
podcast that Dax Shepard and Rob
McElhenney did all the time about body
image and their time at how they suffer
from a lot of body image as well and I'm
sure expert all those ain't no Rob was
he goes dude he got really big for Olli
Sonny Jo Smosh yeah like [ __ ] huge
and he was saying even then I'd look in
the mirror and by God I look fat I look
fat and he goes for him they correlated
it back to when he was a kid and I think
he's around the same age as me a little
older but all our heroes were like
Arnold Schwarzenegger special Sloan and
we don't look like that so but that's
everybody that we looked up to growing
up there's something about that Swartz
Nager like in the Terminator
you know command lone there's stuff
about that like to me that was like that
meant that like that's how that's how
guys look right and even a generation
before us um that's a really good point
it's like even a generation before us if
you look at like leading men it was like
Steve McQueen and Newman and they just
were really well put together guys
they're like they're like fit do that
like that your bodies went crazy I bring
up Steve McQueen with his shirt off he
he looks like it's like me he looks like
Brian yeah that's really or you think
about looking about Kurt Russell and
likely trouble a little China like
everyone like they're like damn he's
body double X but that's a regular body
dude what was the movie but there's a
network that Steve McQueen Russell
Russell played a side Bend em no no Kurt
Russell played a cyborg it's about
soldier the movies called soldier and he
was like a like a half Android bring my
shoes are the first geez act yeah yeah
regular guy that eats like paleo and
he's just like they weren't lifting the
way you know then Arnold came along said
hold my steroids and got in the users
and like I grew up with Arnold yeah it's
like all that that's that's in shape I
was never
big you're a naturally big person those
like you look at Arnold you're like
that's something I do oh you did that
right like this
no I meant big in a good way you're
six-foot what are you six six four yeah
I've always been like not the tallest
guy not even close to the tallest guy
you know I was an athletic guy tall dude
he's not 510 I'm average I'm literally
told I'm the American average is 5 8
I'm 510 and by the way I thank God every
night I'm 510 my mom's 411 oh my dad's
like five six oh wow you had to do so
how about you 9 is there so how about
yesterday I go to buy a bike a road bike
and they're barely letting people and
the guy was kind of an [ __ ] at first
but then he got really nice and was
educating me on bikes what I want and he
looks at me and I go yeah I looked it up
online I'm about a 61 inch bike he
looked at us no you're not 61 man I said
would you uh yes we about 290 300 I go
why he goes
am i offer you yeah dude I'm like 250 is
your 1950 and then you start arguing
about my weight I go dude I'm time like
55 I might be 2/6 he goes yeah either
way you're not 61 inch bike he didn't
break that frame 90 no but his frame and
Brendan's frame is a natural 260 your
brain carries Brendan's that's why
Simmons is like one of those people
where it's like it's unfair you know
like he came out of the womb being able
to deadlift more than I will ever be no
matter how many steroids I do dude I
know from I know now I'm not gonna
mention names but I just know from the
guys who are like the really good
grappler is the [ __ ] legends like
I've heard from other people that when
it come I'm talking about Olympians when
it comes to wrestling and grabbing and
yeah they were good and they were like
they fought a 205 or they fought at 185
they might have fought it even
heavyweight when the Anaconda got a hold
of him in practice yeah
the strength was true I mean he's got
he's very very technical and he's got I
would trade all that for you it for your
body right now it doesn't because you're
so naturally muscular like and
like you know there's some people that I
tried doesn't think so no there's no
that I talk to you that that what they
like hey man how do I get like you and I
and I feel like a dick but I'm like
that's not realistic you're 40 50 and
five seven and have never worked out
it's not 40 that's not you know what I'm
saying like and then Brendan could get
that way if he did some anavar and he
did or when stroke he'd have to he'd
have to eat real quick it's it's on the
same topic yeah but we need to have a
discussion on something that has been
bugging me and I'm not a jealous person
but this is my wife and and this is and
I quote your name came up mr. Tom and it
wasn't it wasn't oh he's he's really
attractive which I'd be like okay that's
my wife goes oh yeah he's damn he's sexy
damn he's sexy Brian film that that's
there's something there right that makes
me angry right because now she has to
have now you have to have sex with her
immediately
i punished her that okay that's another
thing because dinah true should be
joining us yeah at some point this isn't
I'm not you guys are all about big dick
energy yeah okay I have to let you know
this isn't like me looking out for a
buddy here dr. drew is a monster I've
always said a mama said that ask Carolla
ask getting the wife on the phone
it's not a joke he's gonna have the
words on the street yeah I've known
since the first time I did what to get
first I did love line you brought that
up and put together well and I've yeah
put up he's Jack Drew's Jack Shirley
stupid you and me are the most I'll [ __ ]
guys in the room when Michael if you
were here you will just pull up a
picture of shirtless dr. Drew and you
will get I guarantee you go that's big
now he's yes beyond giant last time I
saw my when what are you doing he's so
much good cuz just eating paleo
basically I think listening heavyweight
in his sixties ooh um his jab you have a
podcast I do I just started one man and
I'm a which is what I'm really proud of
it to like I'm really passionate are you
still working on Jason no no we Jason I
like so I do his show jason Ellis every
Friday I'd still do his show but we were
doing a podcast called high and dry I
didn't know that that's what you're
still doing the show yeah yeah yeah
Jason I love Jason Jason's my boy like
we have a weird amazing connection Jason
and I do and I like I really care about
jason Ellis he's so misunderstood
because he's so [ __ ]
Tov and so macho and the exterior is so
weird with the head tattoos and the
[ __ ] antic it's a great guy but at
his quarters like he's one of the most
sensitive people I know really like yeah
you know someone struggling or like like
a puppy with one eye on [ __ ] Jason's
done for the day I believe one of those
guys you know the nicest guy it has his
career I haven't talked him in a while
has and I text him when he came because
he was talking about how he's bisexual
hmm has the has the viewership on the
show gone down or has that be changed I
really a shaming but you're joking I was
like oh I'm bisexual I like dick or
whatever for all the for the ten peoples
are his words over the ten people that
go I'm not listening this guy anymore
he's [ __ ] gay blah blah blah there's
a handful of people and they DM Jason
and they used to DM me wouldn't we when
we were doing high and dry there's these
gay guys out there that go I never had
someone to look up to that was manly
because I'm gay and I'm in the closet
and I love MMA ha I love [ __ ] hunting
and I love the blood like us you know
and and it's nothing there's nothing
nothing wrong with but but realistically
in the media you see gay guys as Lance
Bass and you know the boss but there are
different we heard from Lance Bass and
life but you hear like the guys or dudes
like Jason Jason it'd be so hard in the
paint about MMA and [ __ ] and his
fighting and it's like the guy fought
Shane Carwin he's insane he's a man and
he's very manly in lipid trucks in moto
and the whole thing to also be open and
out of the closet first of all he's a
top what top 15 skateboarder in the
world he was he was in at one point I
mean 91 Europeans are easily I'm the
best in Australian number one
skateboarding Australians came over here
he's top five at one point Jason was top
five in the world in vert skating yeah
rock man yeah talented got in the nicest
guy I think that's his girl no the other
one when he can when he came out and I
saw you saying it was like affect his
numbers like that's such a well why
would you give a [ __ ] what Jason does in
his off time woody what do I have to do
with anything with the show cuz he
doesn't talk about it right on the show
he does he does but it's not like
talking about aleko silk'n to gawk last
night I mean he but he just references
it Oh does he and I think look I don't
know and I don't want I don't like to
point fingers and say like hey you don't
think the same way I do therefore
there's something wrong but I'm I'm in
the same boat as you where I can totally
see the other side of the fence on many
issues how you could give a [ __ ] about
who you fought other one who leather
what other person [ __ ] III don't I
can't even imagine a world where I would
give a [ __ ] that's like telling me
you're brunette yeah okay hasn't
mattered in the [ __ ] you know I can't go
home any sometimes certain guys have
those feelings too and then they're
reminded yeah there could be it all so I
I don't think enough credit gets made
like people don't make enough of an
issue about this familiarity is a bigger
issue than people make it out to be I'll
give you an example we were on Loveline
one time yeah I feel like this one [ __ ]
we um we were on the line one night and
we get a call and this guy goes hey dr.
drew my kid I just want to call because
um my girlfriend she was she was Korean
he was Korean or Chinese but she was
Asian about either Korean or Chinese and
she said he said uh my girlfriend she
moved back to her country of origin and
I found that I really like Asian girls
and I'm like okay cool yeah but he goes
what do I do
and I'm like you're gonna have to
elaborate what the [ __ ] do you mean he
goes I live in rural Ohio like an hour
away from Cleveland where do I where do
I find one and I'm from the east side of
Los Angeles which is essentially [ __ ]
Shanghai you know I know seriously like
if you look at the demographics I lived
in Pasadena area but a little more east
like alhambra Monterey Park I grew up
where more more Mandarin than English on
a lot of the building so I'm like are
you are you [ __ ] kidding me seriously
what do you do I go get a Southwest
ticket to Los Angeles go about 11 miles
east of LAX your head will blow off your
neck there are vine yeah yeah UC Irvine
especially yes but um my point in
talking about that is like there's a lot
of dudes a lot of dudes in this country
who realistic realistically believe
they've never come in contact with a
home
sexual no and for me I have to take a
step back and go okay my life is totally
different it's not that they inherently
have some hate for homosexuals but I
think it's human nature you're kind of a
little bit weirded out by the other
friend because the unknown and and a lot
of people if they just took the time I
wish I could rember the dude's name but
he was a he's a black fella he was on
Rogen's podcast and he literally goes to
kick his KKK yeah
he collects these and and but they're
there guys I think that homosexuality
for a lot of people who come from a
religious background or those ideas have
always been threatening to someone who's
raised to believe in things like
tradition nuclear family the medals of
whether the medals of America and so
that becomes when they think of like
this this this acceptance of gay
marriage and gay so it becomes a bit of
a threat to the foundations of the
things that they've come to love the
theater they've come to defend so
there's a very deep emotional irrational
component to this so by feeling 2020 is
changing it's 20 it's like open your
mind
but most people are I think my I
disagree I don't know if they I hear you
Brian and I think you're right and I
respect actually do respect that if you
have been taught if you're a devout
Christian or a devout Jew and you've
been taught that it's actually sinful to
lay with another man or a woman lay with
another woman I get that and and of
course you're entitled to have that
opinion what I don't understand is how
you can then project that into I dislike
that person or that because that person
would have a metaphor for what what
threatens them is what I'm saying the
little Teresa the same thing and all of
that have it like no no one makes what
case for like we should [ __ ] send all
the good news is the good news is this
is changing worldwide and the proof of
that is Steven Pinker did an exhaustive
study on this with enlightenment now
where you can you can track these things
you can see the age because you can do
it with Social Security numbers you can
you can track the age of what people are
googling the cut you can get a sense of
their prejudicial thinking versus their
not a good database those very
I don't very-very SACEUR days but yeah
because you're not racist er no I'm
saying like I fear gee there's a lot of
people that are like I hate n words well
yeah the F word all these words and not
only that what now all the derogatory
words for these outliers these these
marginalized screw down way down and so
are the joke or they're in the dark so
we're so we're looking up jokes that
make fun of them so they can send them
to friend or do they just DM them to
each other so you start to try to even
one you DMM you even when you see I mean
you have to look there's at there's
usually they originated a base somewhere
in Google or an interesting but so it he
did I don't know the metrics but yeah
that was one of the things they found
that that prejudice is general it's
coming way down across the globe Mike
let me because we're just too connected
it's just you would you connect and
you're rated getting the chance to
actually experience another person
that's different than you makes a huge
difference man it makes it huge you have
a virtual experience did Jason feel like
you had to do it because he and I give
me us I'm almost I might be wrong listen
Jason to tell you I'm pretty sure he
came out when I was on the show I'm you
and I Ron there he was like yeah I
sucked this guy up and I was like I'm I
was just I had no idea I'm like I'm a
bad movie theater suck that guy yeah
[ __ ] yeah I suck dick yeah sounds like
oh wow yeah yeah well well okay well
yeah and you know I look at each other
yeah well [ __ ] do you suck dick let's go
oh I don't know
I don't know if Jason felt like he had
you I know that Jason was reticent to do
it because he knew that it would have an
effect on his listenership yeah but I
think the sponsors drop off ink no no no
and and that's a that's a huge benefit
of the serious model is that they kind
of sell their sponsorship as a package
right I have a theory on all this stuff
like especially with this Kovan 19 it's
the karana virus and stuff it's the
really corona or get just on this ICO
connected this this idea of like what
it's like to be somebody else it's
really interesting because because we
travel so much for sowing could
interconnected as a globe that
everything affects all of us so
whatever's going on in Wuhan is actually
gonna get to me eventually yeah and so
you you you start I think that human
beings are
find themselves more and more in the
same boat and having the same [ __ ]
experience it's really weird that we're
all wearing masks or a lot of us are
that we're all behaving the same way
people didn't want that's a new
phenomenon huge benefits to it you
having a more global view there are some
downside people are gonna close down
signs are stupid what's the downside
I'll give you an example I moved to New
Jersey in 2000 and like I said I grew up
here in LA and I got off a plane and
went and tried to make some friends and
I had a pair of Dickies and some Chuck
Taylors I'll tell ya and these dudes
looked at my Chuck Taylors and like what
are you in [ __ ] hoosiers what the
[ __ ] colors they're all wearing
Timberland booze for sure and parkas and
stuff and vice versa bring some friends
to LA and they're like Nanook of the
north what's with the [ __ ] boots and
[ __ ] and there was like there was this
thing there's cool thing had happened
with music as well like every
neighborhood every area had regional
style at regional corner national
nowadays street style every kids were in
the same social media yeah what's wrong
up you you guys don't maybe don't even
feel this but I was grown when I go to
Europe people dressed so differently in
Europe it was a different world you can
walk around going bam [ __ ] this is when
I was like 20 21 22 23 24 25 you go to
Europe I go to France and people would
be wearing shoes I've never seen and a
style had never seen and just living a
very different life all that every ball
that's out it's all look it's all out
just a bad it's not a bad term but the
culture vulture like Japan with denim in
their shoes collabs and Nike does
collabs over there and then they're the
hottest shoes to get here and grab them
here I really appreciated that though I
mean I love it I'd be a little kid I
visit you know Dallas and I was like oh
these guys are rocking their their
school their thing and of course maybe
coming back a little bit but because
with this virus I think you're gonna see
way more nationalism and the closing of
borders I think you're gonna see the
other dark side of this is darker though
I I do think the United States should be
more self-sufficient I I have an issue
with China and I just don't think
they're our ally in any way they're not
at all anyone could even know were there
there we're in a cold war with them but
but I do think there's gonna be the
blowback is gonna be
let's get way more self-sufficient let's
nineteen ninety-seven percent of our
antibiotics I know made in China
raw materials in China and yeah we a
problem I think when you're that
dependent on a country that we can steal
from us I don't know why people are
afraid to say this but I think because
they think it's gonna be broadened out
to be some type of racist thing this is
what the realities are talking about the
government of China obviously not
Chinese like I mentioned before where I
grew up that was the majority of my
friends were not just Asian Chinese
people obvious but the Chinese
government is it's so aggressively
[ __ ] up yes and I don't understand why
people they are not a relative to like
say that they they are they they they
constantly the amount of espionage yeah
that they conduct the industrial
espionage that they are always they they
have an active state policy of stealing
all of our technology there's a fighter
in the kit in China you just don't know
it I know it
Brandon Chen and Brian they should do
this so many smart in China they should
literally remember my pitch to five
sports you want to do like our
podcasting differently and oh and and
have translators for in Mandarin and
Portuguese Spanish Spanish one should be
like full-on telenovela like over the
top you know just like I think it's a
great idea remember I didn't they're
like Joe it's too much work I so we're
gonna find libel you get them you don't
think we can find comics or all these
other countries you're gonna Mandarin
interpreter and you're gonna you get a
Spanish interpreter ya know it can drool
do French they don't take in 20 minutes
you don't think you guys probably have
friends if you asked around I bet you
within just like the comic community you
could find like six languages
another percent speak French yeah Wow
sort of what do you yeah you know what
you grew up did you spend any time if I
because I know you know I Drew's gonna
be why he's late today
well not late he told me a while ago
this can come in around 3:00 3:30 is
because he's filming I know you got I
don't give a flying [ __ ] but big deal to
me he's filming the reunion my mom's my
mom which is one of my favorite shows
it's actually questions form so grab a
coffee when he comes be
alright I'm glad you brought that up
because people is he get on drew a ton
because the people on Teen Mom will act
inappropriately will act in I don't
think with dr. Drew exactly I was like
dude you understand he spends an hour
with them in a studio at the end of
every season he's not their doctor but
on top of that they don't know what goes
on behind the scenes
those people are [ __ ] up man there's a
lot of super [ __ ] there's a lot of
people who loves here's like scripted
you guys both know that a lot of it's
super a lot of descriptive but a lot of
it a lot of it is is their real life
amber these are people that are
struggling they're kids ever has a
disease it has problems as a kid
especially when you have a kid as a kid
these are struggling kids and and behind
the scenes MTV offers them exceptional
care looked over by dr. Drew Pinsky they
will pay for today only amber and maybe
like one other cast member has taken him
up on it so don't think fire Abrams
didn't who had awful problem she's had
some yes yeah amber needs it but also
that that's their biggest expense from
MTV it's not it's not their salary is
the the therapy and all that stuff
because these kids need all drew Drew's
in a hard place because I think you guys
have probably experienced this but
people don't look at celebrities as real
humans they're they're like a machine
gun are you so nestled a birdie and a
doctor people and actually I'm guilty of
it you you kind of trick yourself into
believing like that's it that's like
some some almost machine that does
things that doesn't human with with
feelings and and and and insensitivity
and she just [ __ ] fire off stuff it's
crazy I was a friend you're saying there
you go oh who says you know they go
who's on your show tomorrow
dr. drum excited I love dr. drew and
they go yeah but where he having my go
I'm just with the current climate and
Teen Mom stuff like that deal he's not
real doctorate but he is though do you
keep saying that
max and doctor in Pasadena yeah he's a
legit he that's his full-time gig he's a
prime just seem on TV he's a practicing
doctor for over like 30-something years
and has was hands-on involved in not
only my recovery but a lot of other
people that you know and he specialized
in 19 he's a
diction medicine specialist and it was
so then in 2002 I've got clean hope you
know by the grace of God for the last
time and that was at the time called Las
encinas Hospital in Pasadena drew was
the head of addiction medicine there he
came Wow numerous times a week to talk
to all of us you know sat down had
interviews with us person to person to
do and so a like you know what the
naysayers what they say they go well you
know a few of the likes especially the
famous ones have not have od'd yeah well
that's any rehab center that's what
those odds are that's the happiest label
relapse
people die that's are able to do anybody
has had experience with people who have
addiction knows that there is very
little you can do as an outside observer
with the best of intelligent rehab the
success rate what is it's like less than
2% not high heat it's but the problem is
faster problem and I'm not I I really
dislike when people try to present this
idea that there's only one way to go
about it the 12 steps worked for me and
I believe in them greatly but there's a
lot of ways to skin a cat and whatever
works for you whatever keeps you off
drugs and alcohol yeah doing I'm all for
it but I will say the 12 steps don't
work a lot of times not because of the
setup of the system they don't work
because people aren't willing to do that
but but a lot to be any program those
people are going to relapse it doesn't
matter who's gonna be there was a guy
ran a rehab a famous rehab center and
he's an older guy very nice i sat next
him on the plane and I said I know
somebody who has issues but I think you
know and I said I think they'll get
better you know they'll figure it out
and he quietly just want my dis he goes
no they won't
ha [ __ ] oh I was like what do you mean
of course no I've had it way too many
times I can't tell you how many how many
poor people I've talked to not literally
poor like financially but I feel so bad
for these poor people who email me who
DM me and they're like my husband or my
wife or my kid is an addict blah blah
blah blah here's what's going on look
and I go oh my god this is terrible you
need to do a B and C I'll say you know
this Petrak well what are a B and C from
my experience this is what you should do
if you really want to nip this in butt
and they're like I was like drop
everything today put he or she or
sometimes it'll be
person themselves they're saying what
can I do I have a problem I'll say drop
whatever your family your job your
schooling stops today you're going to an
inpatient facility for at least 28 days
what if you can't what if you lose your
job and you're [ __ ]
that is a very now there's places around
the country where financially that's not
possible in California you can do it
the state will to the extent that now
you're not gonna get the caterer in
Malibu you're not gonna get the care
that Ben Affleck's getting right now
let's be honest you're not not but
you're getting care what you're so
expensive Mike it's have you ever looked
at we know it's so expensive there yeah
thirty forty thousand dollars all right
it's reading a date what yeah so what is
what is treatment what happens in a
treatment center well in treatment
centers that I'm familiar with like I
said I don't know about all but in
12-step based ones that I'm familiar
with there's a lot of group therapy
you're in there with other addicts and
alcoholics and the the communal aspect
of it is so young people rely on and so
valuable and they're all [ __ ] up like
like a you you you have this weird
notion at least I did I was I was
convinced that my my problems were
unique that my problems with meth and
drinking were very unique to me course
and you get in this world where you see
that oh that's so not true it doesn't
matter if you are a hedge fund operator
working with a three billion dollars
liquid in the bank or you're a street
sweeper or you're out of work literally
a homeless person you have this amazing
similarity and experience and it's so
strengthening it so it bolsters your
ability to take this on head first so
the communal aspect is is awesome then
you deal with kind of the clinical
medical aspect then you have to deal
with doctors literal doctors talking to
you because you can't just wean off it
right because a lot of people die
alcohol's people so because it's legal
you can literally walk down the street
and get a beer no man alcohol is one of
the most dangerous drugs to to get off
alcohol withdrawal is commonly fatal
comas for serious drinkers daily
drinkers for a long time
something about something about the way
it affects you I'm sure obviously drew
if you go zero to a hundred items like
alcohol withdrawal is commonly fatal but
going back to what you said about like
whenever you think your problems are
unique have you ever felt that way when
you're sick like I'll have I had a bad
thing I went to three different doctors
could I add stat sure I had Mercer staff
they were like I don't know meanwhile
the nurse who is the emergency room
nurse have been like around forever
looked at me she goes let me see that
she goes you got shingles honey no I got
says no you got shingles and and it's
one of those things where I thought I
was gonna die that I'm the only one and
they're likely or I had a concussion
nurse I'm like I have a neurological
I've got a brain tumor son yeah she does
what were you doing I go just jiu-jitsu
she goes you got a concussion honey like
you know that's always very comforting I
don't know that it's very commonplace
also I'm giving my phone cats just dr.
drew a pride Texarkana we hate to admit
it because I'm vibrant Americans I you
know this is my feelings on it but
Americans our stress independence is
stressed in a so much in this country
and that's obviously there's a lot of
benefit to that but you the kind of the
cowboy Wild West American ethic is pull
yourself up when you do you you're
responsible for everything that's on
your life and and again of course
resilience self resilience and and
reliability is huge but at the same time
knowing that you have a team with you
when you're doing this is so amazingly
helpful and it just it I hate to get so
corny about it but it warms you up
inside you're like oh this is I've never
met this man this man's my boy yeah this
man's invested you know together you
have [ __ ] you're enough what you got
through the trenches you've gone through
the same experience it's almost like
with Fighters when you've both been in
there you know what took to get in there
you know you know someone got knocked
out afterwards there's this weird bond
yeah and you both went through the [ __ ]
I'm talking about a word like um you
know I can't came from kind of a police
family a lot of uncles and my sister
married a cop and and even if they hate
that dude you know like I you've been
working with this dude that you just
don't [ __ ] like him easy
he's your coworker and he said but he's
still a cop they all have that thing
where he's like yeah
but he's my boy so you know that you got
a group therapy and then what else a lot
of group therapy a lot of still do I uh
actually go to meetings I I was just I
was a steal to go with him to the
meetings he said yeah come and then it
gets late I had a issues the you seen
recovery forgetting me Theo von I did
what kind of drug cocaine I believe it
was his big name a drug oh I didn't know
ballin I didn't know any of this oh yeah
he's recovering
really oh yeah he's he's in the nineteen
stopper I don't like to [ __ ] toss but
I don't like to talk about other
people's recovery he's open about it
about it's different but it feels like
really a good example for people leezak
he's a really good example because he
he's doing the damn thing like there's a
lot of celebrities especially that they
have like addicts and they really feel
like they're different they they can
skate on doing a B and C I'll do a
little bit of D I'll be fine
feels doing the damn thing you know
there's a certain also a big aspect of
it for me that's carried over into my
personal life is the idea of humility
and I I just I I don't want to talk
about myself positively like it sounds
like I'm Tooting my own horn
no please but the one thing I will say
that is a great body
that I have a beautiful body and that I
really did I've really delivered with
cunnilingus but also and I'm happy to
eat a but but also I don't I can't I
can't judge I can't look at someone who
is doing anything and go I'm gonna look
down on you because I can remember very
distinctly living on the pervert living
on the streets having nothing going for
me being an utter piece of [ __ ] looking
through carpet just like this one all my
hands and knees for [ __ ] little
little teeth that's of rock and then
finding some putting it in with clearly
dust and people's foot [ __ ] in the leg
who I got a smoke there's a [ __ ] like
all that dedication and so I was like
who am I to judge a guy that that
doesn't pay his child support or doesn't
you know what I'm saying I go does your
wife have any addiction so she struggled
for a minute off my wife I wouldn't say
she has any addictions she's not
while appropriately had drinking issues
dinner
no you allowed to talk about that no I
wouldn't ask him if my wife's my wife's
um incredibly grabbing I think that's
why we love each other so mine are so
close is that my wife's not one of these
people and and Brian you could speak to
this especially in Hollywood because my
wife is an actress it
you're almost conditioned to be kind of
protective of your image and anything
negative that could put some
vulnerability towards you it's probably
not a good thing but my wife's really
good about like talking about like she's
not my wife struggling with being 43
she's just turned 43 the same females in
eyelid doing or just them is my wife's
beautiful I love my way and she's
everything I could ever want in a woman
I mean she's right here come on do you
do you because your wife struggled maybe
some drinking issues and obviously you
had an addiction do you worry about with
your kids because not because like my
girl just we've had some I don't have
any addiction problems besides society
tonight um and working out kratom
whiskey but if I drink at home it's like
you know put her in a bad side yeah it's
our mood it's not it's not that I worry
my wife and I want to be clear my wife
doesn't have any drinking clinical
drinking problems but what happened was
my wife was very shy and was kind of not
like the popular girl in high school and
then she moved to California to move to
Los Angeles to become an actress and
almost immediately hit it big but she
was in a major much Cox are weird if you
didn't get corona from the Teen Mom kids
you'll be fine here they were all by
Skype holy sky yeah no everything's I've
been around oh well we inviolate of
Corona distancing here right now we are
yeah two of us have fun okay but we even
having sex for a long time oh I don't
know look at them wiping down
Brandon obviously hold him down right
it'll hold him down and drew I'll spit
on your [ __ ] and I had to promise my
wife I promised his wife - yeah yeah you
would I've been I've been pure Elling my
hands religion not touching my hand not
touch my face don't touch your face
that's the main thing okay
and this thing can't do so hard for
Brian did not touch that beautiful face
yeah well I was gonna say I like to
showcase it like this but how was the
Skype dr. drew though I'm a huge I was
telling these guys for you I'm a huge
team mom oh okay so she was it was a
proof-of-concept with Kate that we could
do this by Skype and it was really good
anyway went well well those things are
usually a little bit of us you're just
such it's like you're wrangling cats oh
yeah don't get upset some of them have
come or the ex-boyfriend it come and
it's like how about the emotions run
high and they walk off and then Jews
like no don't come on that's it that's
that's the that's that in a nutshell
he's a real fan yeah oh yeah I think
amber has some real real problems I know
but we've been dealing with that since
she was 16 you know and and people one
of the things that people don't take
into account the cast when we chin so I
get the names it's Bree being pregnant
at 16 is sort of a marker for mental
health problem no it's great people
think about it that way but it's
oftentimes it's really awkward I just
figures kids haven't said some [ __ ]
happens but they all knew it's just kind
of a marker it's I'm not saying it's an
absolute symptom I'm saying that it's
like you add that to a couple of things
I'm saying all right okay because when
you go through all these kids clearly a
lot of them have some mental issues you
owe it all so Kailyn quit having kids
with different dad how about how about
the young and pregnant group they need
that new group oh man I try I talk to
them nuts it was brilliant
I loved it I like the drama that's why I
watch it's a brand it is a [ __ ] show
yeah I love it
I can't watch it cuz I get stressed if
you depressed to watch it that my teen
mom is is bachelor okay that that
because I can eat I feel good about
myself going that guy's a [ __ ] dick
but you know you know what this show did
though I knew it what is it it helped it
really was a verse of conditioning
against pregnant yes it just came out
though the the rate of Grenada jaw drop
academic studies that show the higher
the viewership the lower the teen
pregnancies Wow
because their life is basic [ __ ] show me
in a box boy don't care pregnant doesn't
mean [ __ ] watching people they can
relate to
oh my god but then there's a success
story cuz you look at like Chelsea and
there's some other girls who they're
beasts they're like legit but the comedy
team is yes the gab for sure may see but
the common theme is they have strong men
with the baby daddy my wife's a GU we
were talking about Posner your issues
when she came to loss and it's my wife
like I said she was kind of like not she
felt like not popular and she felt like
she was a you know she hits him
self-esteem usage introverted and and
she moves to LA and gets in acting and
then she's in bring it on like boom she
was in bring it on then with all the
things I hate about you and so she's
like all of a sudden thrust into this
weird world where she's hanging out with
actual like big celebrities and going to
these clubs and drinks are flowing in
she she just became obsessive about like
that lifestyle and it was hard for her
as a young woman to kind of to give that
up you know but she was in pretty lost
her first president my my boys like the
chicken bring it on who fell off the the
thing at the beginning and broke her leg
and she's like don't worry guys I'll be
bad that's right what was the TV show
she was on for a long time
rules of engagement whispered yeah yeah
that was like what most people know my
wife from um anyway sorry no good let's
good you daughters yeah and you are a
real doctor we were singing your praises
about how you are a practicing doctor
and thank you for everything but um
thanks for coming on Cobin 19 are we
overreacting
at the beginning I thought we were and
we still may be but I it's working and
we have some projections that suggests
it's what we ought to do so we're doing
it and like and I've said from the
beginning
whatever the CDC says whatever filed she
says I worked alongside him during the
HIV epidemic and
you did yeah it was you know the guy
knows what he's doing they say
California's like we're set in town uh
kind of the terms of our case for
capital really really we're gonna have
an explosion in the next two weeks the
models out of University of Washington
suggests that we're gonna peak in about
three weeks so we're gonna the end of
next week cuz we're gonna see how we're
doing cuz any question is hide or say
except we're doing stupid [ __ ] like
we're doing today
I do understand how I come in contact
with anybody that where I could transfer
it I don't I'm not around anybody but
that's why we're plateauing so I mean it
when they say we have this huge boom and
it doesn't make sense doesn't it yeah it
does because nobody is around anybody
well do you see the stats which shows
like you know h1n1 and all these other
different viruses that were so much
worse yes I H one when it was brutal and
he killed for it it was terrible killed
so many he killed 40 to 60 rows
routinely routinely and it killed a half
a million people and infected one
billion we were canceled you don't even
know what happened no no Bob issued out
like don't a warning yeah I mean like
hey man we need to call almost died from
it she was 33 at the time yeah it was
time I had it it was sick I got better
watch this sick of [ __ ] for a week kept
going I'm like a [ __ ] no then I got
better and then I got really sick again
that's ten years ago Kovac can do that
too
but let's be fair me cope it's dusty
anymore infectious and it does seem to
be have a higher fatality rate in risk
populations and technically I'm in one
right it will no or population over over
sixty yeah I mean really prostate cancer
and hypertension technically I'm in a
real write a paper
butchers [ __ ] syndrome but it still
killed a lot of people killing people in
their enemies yeah I was thinking mostly
killing older but it's getting a few you
know it's not it's gonna be you know
it's gonna let this with this where we
lose about thirty thousand people to the
flu every year right
thirty thousand right it's a bit on the
sinuous and if this is worse than the
flu we should be up around ninety to a
hundred thousand right so that's what's
probably gonna happen and if we do that
if that happens in such a way that we
don't overwhelm the system success but
h1n1 killed routine
people in their 40s and 50 40 to 60 and
and why wait well we don't know is the
way these viruses are why is this one
only killing old people hey this one has
something to it how it binds in the in
the lung how is how is the
hydroxychloroquine e quinine in
combination this week everything's gonna
be about testing and treatment and if we
do more widespread testing if we find
out that for instance more people are
immune we find that more people have it
they didn't know it whatever we're gonna
learn more about where it really is in
the community and then we're gonna learn
about therapeutics and then nobody does
this better than our country man we we
figure out how to treat stuff and we
come up with good plans and good ways of
intervening and if that us know we'd
kill on that and all the measures of the
US healthcare you know that you know
where we rank relative to some other
country never takes into account
something like this never we do this we
flex we get it done we innovate we
figure it out and and then and if we can
really knock the viral shedding down
knock the hospitalization down knock the
ICU use down then it becomes the flu I
need a lot of ammo I want a well I want
solar I want a log cabin I want two dogs
that are gonna bite somebody and warn me
of intruders I want to let you talk
about that for launch I know I have I
want to be ready and I'm not so much
hands down its course just because me
and Brian have been and people have sent
me DMS we like dude you gotta quit
saying that the you know this virus
isn't that dangerous and cuz people
listen you influence people will start
getting accused of killing people yes
you're killing people just for raising
the issue how aggressive should we be
that's important that's an important
question what is that this is worldwide
best from January 1st to March 25th
coronaviruses is going up 21,000 deaths
by seasonal flu already one hundred
thirteen thousand deaths by malaria
228,000 that's by suicides 250,000
traffic fertility and I think if nothing
else these numbers should help you
calibrate your emotional response to
this that's what I'm saying that's what
I call that it's okay that we the
government wants to go to the mat with
this and control it they feel they need
to good we're all doing this
collectively let's follow our leaders
let's do what they tell us no follow CDC
for sure but don't freak out and don't
read the newspapers and don't watch
cable news don't
they are just trying to watch us an is
try they're trying to spin people a way
I've never seen before drew a lot you
know I do online because Drew is one of
the first medical professionals that's
in the media that was saying like you
need to relax a little bit and that the
media's being irresponsible about it
people trampled a vat into saying dr.
Drew's saying it's not serious and all I
always saw this in a foul Qi listen to
Falchi listen if I know I've seen like
this is the thing that bothers me it's
like I'm gonna do my best to protect
myself and protect my family I'm gonna
listen to every single rule that has
brought down upon me by the United
States government but the unit the the
media has been wildly irresponsible and
they have definite like we can all agree
response they're just powerful they're
they're using this as an opportunity to
save themselves because it was a failing
business model up until you know three
or four what why why this but why I
personally to me is how literally don't
touch me I just now I've crime but
what's fascinating is why this
particular virus and this this I've
never seen in my lifetime there's this
kind of reaction yeah what happened
i we well we created a panic that's what
that i could see it coming i when they
when they started reporting on china
thought oh my god they have no idea what
they're reporting on we have no idea of
knowing what's coming out of China
what's really going on just shut up
until we figure out what's going on oh
no it's the end of the world see a
dramatist rain it here comes who is
saying this was it there breezy no no
that was my point every media outlet you
can imagine and I just shut up shut up
shut up you're gonna make this worse and
now we've you know whatever the
collective spirit is level yeah every
three times let's be fair if we just let
it fly it would exceed the ability of
our hospital to meet the needs and the
serious thing we've never had anything
like that before I think it's not in
recent history and so it's worth making
a giant effort to prevent that from
happening and once we're in we're kind
of into that effort and you know do we
need to completely shut everything down
I think we could have been smarter about
it use technologies and better testing I
hope I hope
and hopefully they won't be a flu you
know it'll be something really dangerous
this is dangerous for some people and
hard to predict for home it's bad and
let's be fair it's bad it's a nasty flu
I mean if you talk to anybody who's been
on a ventilator been through it it's
awful
yeah and you can't and you crash fast
and you get a RDS and that's a horrible
complication there's lots of lung
scarring and problems down the line and
when people spend multiple days on the
ventilator before they get off if they
get off so it's a big deal at you friend
have you seen the some of the footage of
the hospitals if you if you watch the
media they show just it's packed and
it's chaos yeah and then you go the
hospital it's really not like that
because there were shine pictures of
Italy not our hospital rec they were
they were pretending they should be held
accountable those journalists should be
put in jail and how about there being
your response so the people who report
couple dies from taking cola : or
whatever because Trump said so no that's
the headline you take one down you're
like they clean fish tank eating fish
tank cleaner I just think like this is
definitely adding to people's fear and
I'm not saying that's not something to
fear but I do think the spective you're
asking perspective it's not they get a
present and by the way this
hydroxychloroquine might work yeah and
if we get some data towards the end of
the week I mean that I'll change
everything yeah that'd be really cool
I've always appreciated very much your
perspective I listen to it my sister's
obsessed with that she sent me your
thing about going about your business
wash your hands listen to the CDC I
thought your whole take on the homeless
situation when Seth Seth Green I think
his name was was well we got a housing
problem you go it's not housing problems
right now we get right right now they
all have housing that's right and there
go walking C go to Venice that's going I
know there's some in Woodland Hills too
these are all really ill and they have
to put them into treatment and into
housing they will not go on their own
and their you know to fair Newsome's
rhetoric shifted with this crisis and
he's begun to talk about mental illness
and services and treatment he's just not
doing it well Newsom was part of that
whole thing about there was this weird
very strange left-wing sort of wall
against calling this an addiction image
they were just all how they were to
blame the economy and rich yes and how
housing it was the house insurance and
it was almost as strange this strange
thing that they were all they knew the
difference so and they are so blinded by
their ideology I went to the White House
Newsom is disappointing he's had a
stuffed shirt with his [ __ ] height in
his hair but I don't like it look I'm
giving him a good grade for what's going
on right now all right but but he I went
to the White House gave a talk about how
this happened how we destroyed the
mental health salon America and where
they all got belched out onto the
streets and the prisons and the nursing
homes that's it we made know that that
happened that was a Supreme Court
decision and I think it doesn't it
pretty complicated a lot of gay pictures
when he was in the White House that's
not a joke that's so was that we at the
White House three or four months ago and
how was it very interesting is really
fascinating how so well first of all
everyone around Trump there's some he is
some amazing smart people around I loved
meeting the people in the West Wing and
Willie and they're all they are just
about what can we do to make life better
in America that's it what do you think
we should do what do you think what do
you think well I've got some ideas we're
just trying to make things better it's a
these they're super enthusiastic and did
you film as ideas I spent yeah I spent
the whole day with his art with the
secretaries are and secretary Carson and
I just I fell in love with those two
guys oh wow they're amazed and Carson
ben Carson amazing that all would be
with the physician right yes your
surgeon there he is my dude he's pains
himself in south whatever and he's been
he he is really working on the the
outlets thing he's coming he will he'll
all this went down he was on his way to
really take care of what do you think
should happen with the homeless you here
is it's a series of things need happen
they need to change the laws around
mental health and you need to have some
ability to put people in treatment than
the treatment we went overnight in the
early 70s from the criteria for
treatment was the doctor decided that
person needed care to harm to self or
other that's a giant distance it is a
lot in between yes so we said we need to
have the ability you mean physicians
literally yes okay what happens the
stood the Supreme Court decision was
essentially and correct me if I'm wrong
it was the idea that the state
unless you are a danger to others and
yourself the state has no right to take
you and force you in in the treaty so so
in you made a point of saying if
schizophrenic is rolling his own stool
in a ball down the road
that's his possession and technically
now a police officer you can't touch
can't touch it but if it's what you want
to but if it's a demented patient with
the same symptoms and you don't
intervene you're guilty of abuse yeah
what what the hell yes certain certain
brain diseases are privileged and
certain brain diseases or yeah you have
to get treatment you have to put them
somewhere to somebody people though get
caught up in the idea of how do you
define mental illness that's a huge one
right so somebody could have depression
sometimes in their mentally ill right if
if you if your illness has driven you to
the street that's a terrible sign right
that when you've lost everything you've
lost your job you lost your ability to
function functionality is the defining
feature of mental illness can you
function are you in distress you live in
a car are you how are you is your
current adjust course harming you oh
come on can we help them drew oh my god
yes and with the other thing if I can
kill this no flowers ready code personal
storming idea the skits are dining the
schizophrenia if you intervene early you
can change the course of the illness
they can yes dementia is progressive no
matter what yet that's the one we
intervene do you think how effed up that
is that's so effed up well what about
nicotine accrete Oh for what nicotine
for dementia I read a study that it make
sense to me anything that causes
alertness we should do that Oh creatine
that Mike sent me all the creatine stuff
so I think reading every day me too yeah
you take nicotine too doctor we've
talked about I would if needed because
I'm on this sort of carnivore s diet I
haven't needed an appetite suppressant
my weight has been what is another thing
I was not talking about it
I brought him the bad boys from Sweden
the Volt's I'm really through but his
big concern what is this gonna do to my
teeth form it's very interesting thank
you thinking I might want to do that is
it diabetes drug yeah yeah Toby's drug
buddies
dollar a day and they found that most
met forum patients don't get cancer
right it is it has some sort of and and
it's a lunch one drug that is associate
with longevity too i I've done that I've
done it it keeps the glucose levels
yeah it must have something else it must
be so yeah like we just don't know
apparently it makes it essentially like
it be like keeping your glucose levels
low so that even if you eat certain
things be like being on keto all the
time where you're not you're not feeding
anything sugar I heard a lot of actors
take it I don't know there's there's a
big push for metformin in the anti-aging
yeah and I've done some research I'm too
much of a dummy to fully understand it
but what I found though I and this
applies you it can dramatically
negatively impact performance oh for
sure
so they're like warming up some boxes
[ __ ] gas I'll be shredded would it
[ __ ] my high kicks up but well I'd be
the leaner probably because I don't know
I think it's stimulate your appetite can
i [ __ ] yeah I mean you ever know you
could take that one like I was gonna say
any minutes could do that too but let me
go back to my pure from yes sorry I feel
like so wills
we need a directive to physicians that
were there we're required to fill out
whenever somebody gets a major mental
illness diagnosis okay so it just like
we do with it with aging we go when your
brain isn't working right and you're on
a ventilator or you get dementia or you
have an ADD you know pneumonia and
you're unconscious I want you to
destruct me what to do so you have
schizophrenia and when you decompensate
which you will let's write down now
exactly what I should do to help you so
I can have the with the right to get you
off the street and make you better yes
and families are begging for this we've
been up to Sacramento multiple times
begging them for help they have doctors
and resources and money in a home F off
there still get out of here who do you
think you are because it's because it's
it's violates their ideology would you
think do you think your children don't
have agency or save it do you think the
brains don't get sick brains get really
sick and agencies affected I mean our
measurable evidence don't we we ratified
I don't know how much more measurable
evidence you need somebody who has who
lives in a cardboard box and rolling
this [ __ ] right no but I said honestly I
really do think first off a lot of those
people
and I just know this from like kind of
bumping elbows with them in the recovery
community and also living in Venice a
lot of those people don't have any
support network they never had anyone
Horseman in their life they were they
came out of the womb [ __ ] where their
their their their you a drug a drug it
apparent many mentally ill parents maybe
no parents and with pre-existing mental
health problems you're [ __ ]
yeah you know I a lot of times I'll look
at dudes walking down the street like
asking for money to buy a beer at 7:00
a.m. and I and I and I get overwhelmed
by the feeling like man pretty much the
only thing that except rates you for me
was a zip code we grew up yeah is that
my daddy could wipe my ass every time I
[ __ ] up you know what or or sometimes
I think some people you know I have
theory on that like when you see
somebody who smokes weed all day long or
they drink all I think a lot of people
are born with a very low level of say
serotonin or whatever am I sure maybe
self-medicate whatever like my father's
best friend was he was named I was named
after he never felt good deputies over
unless he was drunk and that that
started happening when he was 13 years
old and that's just his wiring and I'm
just lucky that I was born with a
certain amount of genetics where I don't
need that I'm just [ __ ] lucky I see a
wretch on the street sometimes and I
just go he didn't choose that he didn't
[ __ ] choose are you a kid anything
doctor no no never but what mike has a
very poontang but is very powerful a
doctor can you calm down thank you well
he has a very powerful statement about
his relationship with substances III I
think I know what you're referring to is
like I this is you know this is hard to
say sometimes but I have a child and a
wife who I love more than I could
possibly imagine sure more than I could
put into words I'm not sure I can't
confidently say that I love them more
than I love meth and that's that's the
nature of addiction which is why their
families their job don't count they're
why their lives can fall by the wayside
and literally I've had patients say to
me I could
oh no I'm out it's gonna kill myself but
I couldn't do that to my drugs I love
them so so good this is fascinating to
me it isn't so good it's only so good
for people like me I can't do this to my
drug
so Jeremy Tambor you know the actor so
he was he's a great actor and he was
trying to play he had to play an addict
and he couldn't figure out it's not an
addictive personality and he couldn't
figure out like how to connect to it
right so he he spoke to an addict and
the atticus I don't know how really
described he goes well can you give me
something because he said I mean I guess
I guess you know sometimes when I would
I when I would think about it like
sometimes I would come I got it what
that was real
that's cocaine yeah yeah we'll do that
that's right he said that was the drazi
stimulant it's like that one teen mom is
it Macy's baby daddy who's just a drug
addict and there's a scene in Teen Mom
where like the way you see everything
through the prism of team I know but
he's driving he's high
oh he's right mama and he's fall asleep
not on the highway they're filming this
there's a GoPro nice I see in the ends I
didn't say getting back to what we're
talking like the worst data getting back
to what we were talking about earlier
you know where you said like in your
mind all of you are probably I'm not
maybe not him but here's thinking how on
earth could you drive with your child
[ __ ] up I can't sit here and judge the
guy I drove intoxicated every day not
with your kids or no and but I have my
phytic aid at 19 absolutely I'd be happy
I'd be high behind in front of the with
AB so thank you you know this is where
you where compassion has to play and and
not taking credit for your like I always
try to remember not to take credit for
the fact that I'm somewhat successful
and I'm not kidding and yes and
beautiful but it's all but in other
words it's well it's just I was given I
was made lucky luck but but what do I do
with that a lot of it's luck a lot of
it's luck but a lot of it is hard work
innovation and allant like bother you
also come in here for last seven years
every Monday Wednesday late and
my back hurts from what you still come
but I got seven years right but again I
was raised with that work ethic with
that idea where we're no wow huge flaws
drop like it went entertainment show
sabotage I know yeah I had a hard time
you've got so you had self-sabotage for
a long time but you it was always but I
was always at the same time I was always
I had these I had a stable enough life
and upbringing and mentality born with
that where I was always able to
accomplish things right still you know
what I'm saying like I leave [ __ ] hit
the road how far do we go with this you
didn't get neuroblastoma when you were 2
you know I mean I didn't know I mean yes
getting through life is intercourse a
crazy navigation it's amazing we get one
day to the exit but well you know you
maybe people just don't have the
machinery and maybe that's what I'm
saying
yeah but should you then feel bad for no
no it brings up a larger question which
is the question of free will that's all
I'm saying and that will complicate
there's a there's an argument to a man
I'm looking at I'm ago a tablet from
throw science view it's like there's a
little bit of it's like a nice little
goulash there's some there's some nature
and there's some [ __ ] nurture and is
plenty weird
directly with your career like dude
we've talked about it you you you gave
one podcast a shot didn't work out you
didn't [ __ ] throw in the towel give
another one a shot you gave away you met
this guy then Muppets yoga hey let's
give it a shot [ __ ] and then feast in
season that you know the arms kept
showing up showing up and you would like
a Joan Rivers said on on Louie show I'll
never forget it man she did there was an
episode of Louie back when he was still
allowed to make content we're now
special ok that's pure fire and Joan
Rivers was again he had just done a
terrible show at like some casino and he
went up to Joan Rivers room and she says
you know sometimes the music's gonna
stop in your career you just got to keep
dancing yes and it's like the people
like me that just it doesn't matter
house [ __ ] good you just gotta get
stopped for a while for her yeah stop
yeah while for her she couldn't she no
one would answer her phone calls and you
know so be it's true in a lot of areas
of life though right things can turn
down turn up you you just you keep
working you work hard you hope you do
the right thing a little bit like you
know your life is
gonna have doubts we know this it's
exactly like we are going to be faced
with black swans it's gonna be that's
right
here's the black is this is the Black
Swan your shits gonna happen where
you're gonna be like can you believe
this shit's happening can you believe
that I am thrown into chaos that my 401
K or whatever it might be where I don't
know where I'm gonna go next that can
happen and I can become dr. drew do you
ever have people that come to you to ask
him for help especially with addiction
and you know you're wasting your time we
like this yeah it can roll your eyes oh
sure but but I'm still willing to work
with people if they'll stick around and
hoping that and I'm always amazed
sometimes people that I didn't give a
shred of hope for oh wow Forrest debuff
horse was treated 22 times I explained I
do him back when he was a rock star that
really aids and I like hold NACA Loni's
polonius monster yeah and I'd ever heard
every one you got it this guy's dying
get away and he cannot be oh yes yeah he
was one of the examples in one of the
sub area slowly rehab counselor there
they ought to have the glasses yes and
and and I was giving a lecture one day
and there was a guy sitting the front
row look just like him was like 15 years
later and the whole time I'm lecturing
I'm thinking Jesus Christ how weird guy
looks like Bob Forrest well he's dead
there's no way it's Bob for us and lo
and behold he had recovered and became
this very talented clinician you know
where people are kick out of treatment
well somebody come up to me years later
and go shake my hand to go you know I
wasn't ready to hear at the time but
you're kicking me out was one of the
important things that got me where I am
and now I'm getting my PhD I told you I
told the girl one time I was dating I
swear to God I was young I was too
stupid and she was she was an actress
and she kept talking about how she had
worked with such-and-such but she had
been an extra on things and then I
helped her with an audition and one day
I looked her I go I go can I be honest
they she's never done this you see I go
I don't think you're an actress I don't
think you have it have you seen that she
come on the effects was that's a scene
in effect yeah she called me 10 year
five years later and said I just want
thank you because I have a great life
and I know and you were right she
[ __ ] walked out on me
she won't know what I mean
we that's another thing we weirdly in
like the only last like 20 years
Americans have adopted this like your
dream can come true it's like hmm oh I
can dream all I want about being on the
Lakers yeah that won't ever I have like
a 20 inch vertical and I'm 510 he can
dream about being Jared Leto it's not
gonna happen I don't have the bones from
doing with an bar even if you were a
junkie you would come down to about 200
225 if I was on making afraid I get down
the to 225 to 210 you'd still be huge
you know how [ __ ] up mob force was no
Anthony Kiedis said well I can't party
well that guy's pulled the herd anaphase
House down twice oh my god good boy he's
a real wild child you can never give up
hope man I don't want to sound corny you
can never give up hope on any act no
matter how bad they are no matter how
much you see they seem like a lost cause
alternatively because they sometimes
just surprise you and it gives you hope
for anybody
alternatively though you can never get
to come you can never get completely
confident ever about anyone in recovery
Wow no you just got to be always skipper
DJ am DJ am was the guy I looked up to
in recovery he was my go-to DJ em was he
was I would with the most resistant
cases I go come on man I need your help
but then the Black Swan gets in a
accident accident and set on fire
never underestimate my peers how how
much they do not understand addiction so
he gets in this accident
he has a bad trucker he starts having
panic attacks appropriately giving
painkillers appropriately giving anxiety
medicine try to break this get him up
they get him off everything but he
starts having more trouble more trouble
more trouble and a doctor goes you need
to take this you've been getting an
injury you're not going able to fly
without this just take it when you fly
we're all like oh Jesus come on and they
this is this is a severe drug addict
he's a really serious and what opiates
write a xanax and and and like Norco
and and it's sliding on off on off
finally his his therapist gets ahold of
him and he gets with the at the sober
community around and they get him sober
they have people traveling with them and
he's doing fine he's doing fine
and then he goes back to see a
psychiatrist the doctor goes all right I
don't
mr. pain doctor and he goes I don't know
when you're gonna stop listening those
people are trying to brainwash you I'm
your doctor take these medicines two
weeks later his death how crazy is that
and so that's what I mean about like you
never you can never ever get justice
because of me and completely completely
confident about anyone cuz I used to go
to meetings I'd be like man that guy's
doing it and he would walk up to you and
introduce himself and he would ask if
you had any problems he would volunteer
to sponsor people who's the best
he was it he was it like that's why I
join up I'm John Jones dr. drew what
should we do about John Jones do you
know about him I know a little bit he's
so he just last week his third DWI you
didn't know he's gonna have to history
DUP yeah what so and as Dumberer says
there's always wiggle room at rock
bottom
I thought his rock bottom was when he
got stripped of his bail and Jimmy one
was dead you how many times and look at
him
I got I used to so what do you wake up
manic I reached wake up in the ambulance
so much that it stopped being special no
one I just feel like oh well John's
charge on every bit of six five my fear
is you still tears what's gonna make a
prediction he's gonna end up in prison
that's gonna make him worse but here's
the promise because it happened during
the krona times this his third offense
yeah do you see what they did with in
accommodator the commuted no night in
house arrest
there's nothing he's ain't gonna fine
but that man they gotta have they gotta
fall hard they got have some real
serious car
what's he fall is bigger than life
because he is you know what I mean and
so when they're when reality is part of
the picture it's really hard what was
the drug he was on oh I'll call him and
firing a gun and he was hanging out with
homeless people at 4:00 a.m. almost
people one reason you do that yeah drugs
you looking for drugs and that's where
he'll end up spending more and so it's
all your problem so let's say let's say
he's housing so let's say you're Dana
white or you work for the FC
what would you do to help John to see we
can't write because he said he was going
to rehab
he told Arowana era I said this with his
podcast Daniel Cormier he goes he went
to rehab and I talked to me sure left I
he goes every summer I'm go to rehab
just just because I felt so good I'm
gonna do
every summer and he said right before he
fought Dominic Raees which was just a
few months ago before the fight
John was drinking again which is a bad
sign before the fight he was it was
before super all Sunday he's at in Miami
4:00 in the morning drunk yeah this is
the weekend before the fight and arrow
goes to him are you still going to Rio
miss I don't need it anymore right
here's the Bravo John Jones and I'm not
saying this as someone who has any
expertise in this I'm saying this as a
guy who can see it yeah and I've seen
this unfortunately too many [ __ ]
times where it'd be either an attorney
or or a someone in finance it doesn't
matter an entertainer I knew personally
some people are too talented for their
own good
yeah what's John Joe they're the most
people if not all people in light we
have my heavyweight division without
training at all but he's but he still
he's barely getting by now Pete these
guys because because some people thought
he lost his last fight some people say
lost by please edging by so you think
you'd like alright I'm a [ __ ] but I
need to get it someone in control cuz
I'm close to losing maybe I have a close
friend of mine who's a world-class
grappler who when he and I kind of got
cleaned I know yeah but he's not open
about his struggle so I'm trying to did
he fight too no just just grappling but
he's a ADCC champion and he and I kind
of got cleaned together and he and I
care about each other very much and he
had a lot of struggles early on because
he could literally stay up all night
smoke four packs of cigarettes hit that
hit a couple bumps on the way to the
mats and crush every time so and because
I I I could look at it and go I
literally had nowhere to go I was I was
in a hotel in Inglewood with at day time
watching Jenny Jones [ __ ] hit tinfoil
made of little tin foil pythonic and and
I just ruck one [ __ ] look at myself
in the mirror and I was like oh this
there's nowhere to go
yeah I can die or I can do something and
that was it and seeing yourself for
yourself as your are is off of these
moments of clarity so you got to have
that but Mike's point is well-taken is
that these guys that have lots of power
lots of money incredible ability lots of
trauma growing up
lots of narcissism and lots of drug
addiction and biology very hard thing I
don't chop to him dr. Drew and no for
what I'd be wanting someone like that
spent two years away he's what you don't
hear that you had two years away that's
what two years Freeman he means two
years away in treatment two years away
from the sport years away from life so
he's not fighting for a year is that
what that 100 fight he'll fight this
year well yeah I thought were the you
know that there was so certain okay that
hasn't violated any is he allowed to
fight in terms of the judge giving him
this is a month okay
he's so the US he could fight labs Jim a
fight in November
he's not gonna do anything Joe how is
show that's the other thing is the UFC's
they're they're they're playing they're
playing ball as long as they can with
John core CD that's the fell doesn't
play that game not not as not hole to
hold up doctor not as much like Antonio
Brown like we just used to do we can't
we [ __ ] can he's no different than
Antonio Brown that the biggest problem I
had with any celebrity performer
musician was that they were broke going
back to Bert work to prematurely and
they were they made so much money and
the people around them wanted to them to
do it it was always always what kind
also to stick up for entertainers and
athletes there's a famine mentality
about your work if you're a great
attorney or your great bank or your
great electrician you can always go back
to your work when you everything is you
know like you if you if you're a comic
or an athlete a fighter every [ __ ]
day away from you're like I'm losing my
careers I saw that yeah I saw that
firsthand with a certain actor who was
making a group of people a lot of money
and he had a spin out on cocaine beyond
and I remember his Asian I've heard him
say don't worry don't worry we'll get
him we'll get him sober and back to
India oh jesus you I remember it so well
I was like this is LA I was like fine
guess what happened to him he spiraled
even worse but it quarter you think with
John at some point because this is third
of fancy I think he's at for now you
think someone in his nucleus his team
would go dude with whatever doings not
working he he will he will start to
jettison
buddy that gets in the way of his music
them out yeah he was cute and so yeah he
just used you eventually he'll have a
ring of insular people that you know
just keep him it's such a shame yeah
that's what I was think about too much
talent for his own good is because also
people like that they can create a world
where they don't have peers yeah because
you know like realistically John can
justifiably go into Jackson wink and be
like I don't know you yeah I don't need
nobody's I don't need a party with you I
don't need to bro out but guys aren't
there aren't there drugs that can keep
you off alcohol aren't there drugs you
can take yeah it allow you to have one
drink later than just outlaw yeah so so
but there's two basic sort of zones of
pharmacology in this one is in El Trek
zone which for some people really do
reduces their desire to drink and they
sort of reward they get from it but
you're talking about an abuse it which
makes people sick if they drink yeah and
guess what they do if they want to drink
it's not about the own take the [ __ ]
abuse or if they have an abuse implant
or stuff that they chew it out of their
arms I've seen that seriously oh yeah
I've also seen [ __ ] I've also seen
someone I wouldn't call my friend but I
ain't ins who got on an abuse and just
took up pills and switch smoking weed
and eating pills all day yeah I don't
know what you do with John I've no idea
it's gonna play out it's gonna have to
play out how it plays out I don't know
that anybody has any controller I guess
the only thing sometimes for some people
is like you we always say death or
bottom meaning bottoming out and
bottoming out is really bad I thought
John hit his bot with his rock bottom we
hit that lady and she was pregnant and
she broke her arm and he went back and
got the cash and they strip his title
and spent it for two years I was like
that's rock bottom for that man nope
how was he 32 also drug addiction when
he's 42 how bad it's gonna get I'm not
making I'm not making excuses for John
in any way but drug addiction changes
you it turns you into a person that you
don't like being you commit you and turn
into a criminal or maybe not even aware
of the fact that he's changed so to add
this and do it too doctor might add in
CT you're crazy if you don't think this
is also CT mix on top of the mattress
Ted diction because they release the
footage of him being stopped over for
the DWI and the cop goes I want you to
do this this and this and he goes oh she
can tell you my short-term memories bad
I get punched in the face my short-term
I guess so I know you're gonna think I'm
drunk which he is he was but drunk or
not my short-term memory is awful from
fighting and you're like oh well that's
not good
oh and you're the cop plus there's I'm
over you like oh [ __ ] what if he just
turns on me oh this guy wants a visca
this is the same cops pull them over two
or three times in our line form so
there's a bad time there's underlying
mental illness or two of something yeah
thing whether it's mood disorder bipolar
is is that typically in is that
typically a sister to this yeah I mean
if we're both by whatever you've done to
yourself and wherever you've gone with
your drug addiction um however you've
affected your brain with the drugs that
you're using you could precipitate a
mental illness by trauma is sort of a
typical and inciting influence of
addiction and trauma has its own set of
mental health can I ask you this I've
seen this - well you see somebody who's
totally fine most of the time and then
they go on spurts or they have like or
though so they'll be totally normal for
two weeks and then they'll take three
days and be complete [ __ ] record
binge alcoholics yeah what is that about
that they're they're a special group the
binge users there and they're tougher to
treat because they convince themselves
they can control it yeah because they
kind of do yeah right I don't want to do
it I'm not gonna do that again
oh yeah I learned my lesson this but
then they it gets really bad boom it
happens and I I don't want to confuse
people with what Brian's talking about
like it's super real don't confuse that
with like I'm a normal dad and I work
hard and then every three weeks I go to
Vegas and do a couple bumps a blow no
that's no we're talking about you go
from zero to 1 million babies that the
thing is is with those people they can
say all they want and and they're full
of [ __ ] during those three weeks they're
white not so not to go back to Spencer
Tracy Katherine Hepburn and hurt that
boy he said he was one of the movie
stars grow back he would she knew cuz he
would check into a hotel he would
disappear he checking all hotel getting
a bathtub put a [ __ ] towel around his
neck and drink for three days until he
just passed out he would do it right in
the bathtub so he could hose off pee
whatever
she would come to his hotel room and
sleep at the foot of his bed and just
wait for him to go through that it's
just she loved him more dr. drew have
you have you seen that documentary
everybody's talking about Tiger King oh
yeah there have to be some addiction
right oh it's all drug addicts right
they gotta be the one my wife my wife
and I watch and we just like oh Jesus
some of that drug addicts I'm Tiger
because more importantly have you seen
homeboys nanny what's the most important
it's the sleep so they're good for him
one of the owners the real shitty what
he was looking for her he goes to the
computer he's looking through looking at
this headshots essentially and then
wife's like I don't know he goes yeah
what have something to look at why not
oh my god smile I just want for one
second the idea of bringing her home for
my name look at my wife's face oh that
guy is such a psychopath yeah it's a
mixture of these like like it's like
insanity drug halti stuff with the guy
with the weird the guy with all the
girls that he his name is some he's got
some rock Doc Avery yeah yeah oh my god
it's such an addiction though I was
watching like a father well there's a
lot of got with no teeth with the math
yeah the guy at the end strung out on
heroin and the straight guy he turn gay
and that mother the mother of the son
who was also terrible she was on
something sugar headband there's drugs
any drug will put you around people you
don't want to be around they surround
you with people that you don't like
methamphetamines in another level the
the the the world of methamphetamine if
you are unfortunate enough to have
forever get into it is so violent and so
gross and so crazy it it only gets
hotter doing that no no Mike is a good
story go to buy meth out of the desert
oh so my friend we would normally we get
we would get meth from the
guy this guy was not over he said but
I'm going to because you have been
buying meth for me for like six months
straight I'm gonna give you the number
for the guy I get it from you cut out
the middleman
yes smart and I go oh hi Burt and we go
out to the Apple Valley like straight
out of [ __ ] Breaking Bad we are
driving forever into tumbleweeds and
cactuses and there's this [ __ ] Shack
and this dude comes out and greets us in
a wife-beater not like super buff but
thick shave head fully fully visible
swastika and SS tattoos and were like oh
what the [ __ ]
yeah what do we do it and my friend
moves with me tougher and cooler than I
am is he Latino no he's he's like he's
like a surfer brah white guy he goes
white it's alright yeah and and he was
like I'm so area so he gets and we're
like okay he's like you Conan so we we
go inside and this guy's name is vamp
and he has he's like 11 feet tall and
like 90 pounds in and his hair is jet
black down his booty neck tattoos nope
no - oh wow oh um shirtless but thin
thin teeny like imagine like like like
Marilyn Manson like at his peak when he
was finna look kinda like that and we go
to this table and he has a [ __ ]
collection of meth like big rocks of
meth and we were like don't you guys why
I don't know maybe like you think
quarter ladies I go you know that'll be
250 bucks and we like armed okay yeah
let's go got a standard price to him 40
bucks we were buying we were buying like
a lot of my all the meth yeah we were
but we were buying more like typically
buy like an Eightball but you we were
getting like a quarter I think or he
calls how much I've no idea behave and
outs so we're gonna owe a baaaad in 1996
it was like 75 to 100 bucks cheaper now
right I don't know it's probably more
prolific now sees me more ubiquitous so
it might be cheaper but
we sit down at the table a big serving
the table but big and we're sitting
there and a [ __ ] place is a mess
the teeny little [ __ ] jacket he's
messin and we're talking and there's a
cat over here to the counter by the sink
and the cats walking all looking all the
[ __ ] and there's an empty open box of
chips ahoy know what bat was a mini bag
of chips ahoy you know like than
anyone's
yeah the personal package that answers
and it's open and the cat's putting his
head in like this and I'm looking over
that and all of a sudden here guys
pulled a gun out from the table and
[ __ ] shot the cat just like a cartoon
and you know a gun shot is especially
when you're not prepared for oh my god
why Brian he's just staring me dead dead
eyes like this and my friends trying to
play cool he's like I said he's tougher
than the friends like I can handle
himself probably in jail like I'm a
[ __ ] chill chill bro chill it's okay
and and I'm [ __ ] terrified I mean III
didn't pee myself but I was so close and
I was so close to crying like a [ __ ] in
front well cause he's pretty like I'm
gonna die now yeah I'm like not only not
only did he fire a gun indoors kill the
cat he had a gun hidden that he didn't
want it's a lot of process so we got so
far
get in the car and we're driving and
we're silent for like 30 minutes and I'm
look over the past year I was like dude
never doing that again I'm never talking
to that guy again I'm never [ __ ]
dealing with that that is one of the
most traumatic things that's ever
happened 10 minutes after we were done
with that bag
Wow the TV apart like to whatever you
see things be taken apart it's always
mad I took my friend Jason Sutton's
television apart because I was convinced
Conan O'Brien was talking to me 90s TV's
like a giant now can you smoke we know
it might sound like a dumb question but
I do know people in recovery who do
smoke that's a mistake
marijuana maintenance okay again I'm not
[ __ ] on it if you're smoking weed if
smoking weed keeps you from doing
opiates or heroin yeah fine lesser evil
absolutely but let's not kid ourselves
like you are because I exchanging an ADD
addiction and someone with the brain
come in there's people who are pot heads
that are not drug addicts there's
definitely people who are drug addicts
that pot is their drug of choice so how
you can go on you so what dude you'll
just do nicotine now you won't touch
anything else caffeine and nicotine is
the only thing going through those don't
seem to trigger that system that reward
system that's association will you drink
dr. drew drink alcohol yeah sure
that's a week your Wootton month
tonight's week maybe yeah well what's
your drink of choice I was like wine but
I'm on this you know carb free things
I'm bourbon carnival oh good for you
very man yeah that's right I got I don't
smoke weed nice smoke weed last night I
don't want to drugs lately I'm a drug
addict okay this quarantine thing is
Research Forum school I was kidding
about that but I will if it's around all
right let me tell you something right
now I did I smoked I took two hits
I don't know from weed I was so [ __ ]
high I don't know how people can think
they can function on this I guess they
do I literally was like maybe you can
understand maybe you can answer this for
me when I do when I smoke weed I feel
every pain in my body I can feel my body
insanely and I start to get paranoid and
I go I think my neck is gonna [ __ ]
paranoia is is that what it is yeah and
then I paranoid a pan and then I watch
that Harvey on Price is Right clips and
I laugh
part of them
my life they do her we're in Austin we
were with Aubrey where we're at I don't
know where it some girls up part my
thing is I was making um got high and
off weed
you were laughing so hard that laughing
is the one that's gonna fall off the
edge of the yeah I was making him laugh
it'll make it'll make really mediocre
entertainment Fanta my god I dunno
they're beginner I heard you guys got to
recognize like you're to both perfect
examples the human body its chemistry so
unique from person to person yeah I know
like a you and I are the same and when I
used to body build there was a guy named
Mike Salcido and we both trained
together we were both almost exactly the
same size he was 510 about 185 and we
trained together too for a show together
to work towards it we both had the same
guy doing our nutrition a couple weeks
out from the show he was eating three
400 grams of carbs a day if I eat over
50 I'm asleep you know so that just
giving you some idea about chemistry of
us like there's people like like Joey
Diaz his brain just it kicks in the weed
he's ready to do it let's do better some
people you're done for without legs me
go to sleep
I knew and other people go up yeah it is
cream girl named Mary she was 75 pounds
I mean honestly she was little and she
could eat hey I watch eat handfuls of
vicodin and guzzle that's just good cuz
oh and she was just straight like lemme
she was like a little Asian living and
then and then I had a buddy was an
offensive lineman at UCLA and he took up
a pill skirt and it's [ __ ] oh that's
my saying like everyone's Kim she's all
you know there's a grown up and we'll
get into that bodybuilding some people
are addicted to steroids yeah it's super
addictive and I don't know if the
chemicals it sells out a real thing oh
yeah its serialize across addiction
stimulant and steroids spirits the
steroids go together I don't know if
it's a I don't know I mean it's got as
big as meth is but it it definitely
something you have trouble stopping
here's the problem if you're the person
who's willing to use steroids
essentially abuse them you're very
invested in your musculature yes up
that's all you get these results and
then to consciously go I'm going to stop
doing this and I'm also going to get
hormonal
where I get emotional and [ __ ] and my
I'm not gonna have a libido for a couple
months and I'm gonna get smaller and
like [ __ ] that give me some more let's
go yeah that's why I'm terrified to do
any TRT I am at 53 different though here
T's much different of still yeah I do
charity is to get you back to normal I
just I'm gonna be you're not gonna get
your levels to allow right I just
worried though that I'm gonna get to a
point where you get on tier T and then
again it's the slippery slope of not
being able to get off it you probably
would well why would you want to get off
I don't know monel whole therapy that's
a big difference
do you understand it's a big if I'm
convinced it's good for a lot of people
I would take it if I could but I've got
prostate cancer so [ __ ] here so you
can't so it's not how Jackie is now can
you imagine I just need really loved if
anybody in jail I'm not where I was in
my like thirties I feel the difference I
don't think anybody's yeah if you say
you have prostate cancer yeah you had
prosti had but I've still got a little
PSA level I might need some time I need
some radiation who knows you see he
doesn't shoot loads yeah ghost loads bro
when your prostate creates semen that's
all it does and we take it out you know
to produce fluid anymore yeah yeah it's
like guys like a magic trick young and
pregnant could [ __ ] use those yes so
covet 19 don't touch it face keep your
hands at your face that's all that's all
collectively go sign up to do we're
supposed to do is follow our leaders
direction if we get any [ __ ] for this by
the way we've all been very good [ __ ]
just we're not practicing six everybody
blows here but you're keeping your face
this way I'm keep my face this way I'm
not touching you especially during the
time the Quran appreciate you guys
coming out man both of us freaked out
what's the name of your podcast
Mikey likes you thank you and it's you I
really really really believe in it I'm
really touched on the question with
these days it's uh it's a podcast about
health and fitness but it takes an
exageration mental health and is it just
you it's just me you know a lot about
that I really do and I'm really
passionate about what Mikey Mikey likes
you hey he's my chance love why never
comes back there's a chance that we and
I could do an advice show together again
there's no chance of Loveline coming
back because they still do it the
company there that does it but we don't
know you don't know in the name that's
it's just called love lines so you know
the I guess the Surgeon General said
that they want the CDC to re-evaluate
the whole mask for the mask you know I
think they're gonna all this is about
making sure they're adequate masks for
the frontline people right so we should
definitely wear masks if we can like the
ones I like a handkerchief I got I think
you ought to wear something over your
face because the main thing is we've
sent here already today's hands to the
face is the main problem and if you have
a scar for your face it reminds you not
put your hands on your face and whether
or not actual masks you know change
what's going on intermittent yeah I'm
not aware yeah I'm not sure but I'll
tell you what I think I think there's
something that people are not giving
enough thought through to and that is
the elevator elevators we know that this
this virus of aerosol eise's and can sit
there in an aerosol for two hours now in
a room like this probably just
dissipates and the fact is that people
don't get it without some direct
contract but in an elevator it's just
it's in a box and it's just held there
and you're walking in and taking a big
breath two minutes later Ken really
silent so elevators I think you should
wear bath okay what about bukhara dr.
with semen so macaques fine perfectly
well we love you guys man thinks it's
such a relief to go out and do something
kind of normal I can't wait I'll risk it
man I just can't wait to hear this can I
get you guys something to drink don't
you want to be around people I want to
be in a restaurant I love that though I
love that everyone's more excited about
being social communal I love that yeah I
do i don't i'm fearful though that we're
gonna break into two camps with is over
we're half the camp's gonna go we kicked
it to ass we got out the other half
psych ward we do that it was an
excessive thing yes lost my job I lost
my business I do find myself texts and
friends that you know usually I only
text them if there's something going on
if I seem a store I do find myself
checking up on you're never like he's
caused me everything you wanna do
something this is change of people
without without any work or anything to
go to are you just destroying your wife
is she's walking like she's like
because don't work we goes back I
understand it in her Nana's a lot more
these days I will say that the the the
Asian cultures that bow and don't touch
right and I wondered maybe that's where
that came from somewhere back on shorts
where I came for a it's it's where you
give you shoes off before you walk into
a house if you like Korean life might
tack on a teacher he was like the first
time I saw Americans walking into a
house with shoes on I was like oh [ __ ]
you are you kidding me even having a
bathroom in your house was always
considered like have it outside it's all
kind of you know so I'm gonna have an
outhouse take your shoes off bow to me
you fall he lets bow to each other from
now on from now on to say I just like
inventing a new signature yeah yeah I
didn't know having something should be
very Aryan to me dr. drew have you seen
that documentary the the devil next door
what was it about it on Netflix is about
the the Nazi concentration camp and he
he escapes the war and he's living in
Cleveland when they find him and he's
referred to as Ivan the Terrible I put
my on trial in Israel or it is I may
have the survivors yes identify them but
they he says it's a mistake of identity
it's amazing if you need something to
watch like that I don't watch a lot of
TV when it gets dicey because you go
back and forth three like it's
definitely ivan the terrible' and then
it's like it's not him but then you'll
find out what rip through ozarks ripped
through Fagin I just showered ozarks
last night for the first time watching a
lot of TV I know dad's is sweet if you
guys haven't gotten it what is it
fleabag is my fleabag was it's [ __ ] a
missile but if you see how ago though
yeah we back is great but devs are sick
what's that on big guy Alex garland who
did ex machina and oh it's on Hulu yes
it's called devs devs per developer
development it's a amazing show about
about corporate espionage the it's very
near future where technology it's
Silicon Valley has gotten out of this
world and so Chinese Russian spies are
trying to infiltrate though pretending
to be programmers and real feminist very
handsome and she is terrible pants she's
a terrible show really see that I heard
of it shits Creek speaking of shows I
haven't ever watched 13 Brian found out
that your boy Frank Grillo moved in next
to Frank Grillo didn't ya neighbor made
my I've always been a fan of his bleep
he dress I might go for a jog with my
daughter you know during this lot and
there's just [ __ ] beautiful Frank
Grillo out of Haiti Frank real body die
he goes yeah yeah I was like he's the
best should work out together I would
love you just uh I don't know I feel
very insecure around him he's bodied
watch him watch him box watch how he's
very good right like I've I you know
what I gotta admit
Mario Lopez is [ __ ] pretty good for
ecstasy for a celebrity he's owner in
the West wild-card oh yes yeah yeah
ownership because there's a lot of
celebs who say they train itself you're
like okay yo Frank's the real Frank
would beat the [ __ ] I'm Mario Lopez yeah
that's a good friend Frank and box and
he's [ __ ] already he's got that
mentality is a 50-something four years
old now listen it's Frank or Mario gonna
pass it you saw the drug test probably
not Mario might I don't know much longer
we'd be a lockdown guys what's your
prediction
I say another month he's got a good guy
I don't think Americans even put up with
it after the 30th I don't go to
attention yeah I noticed the freeways
get a little busy or two that's why
every morning I Drive and I'm like oh
I'm Monday I'm like damn it's kind of
busy yeah yeah
so go to kovat 19 health data org it's
where all the UW models are from that
guy Murray and he adjusts them every day
they're very good very accurate and
they're they give a really interesting
kind of there it is go to you go to down
further okay there's the confidence that
pink is the confidence interval for how
many essentially Hospital does we're
gonna need and how about you know you
can send go C word says United States of
America click on that and then click
on California and you can see the data
for every state it's really well done
and he adjusts it all the time and makes
you feel a lot better when you see it
like look how far we are from utilizing
all of our read that's the death that's
the that pink is potential for us to
overcome our resources but the dotted
line is the yeah okay so so if I a comic
I know is gonna book a show end of June
and Spokane do you think that'd be safe
maybe it might mmm a nice a very
definitive June its optimistic it's
optimistic okay yeah you're not here's
here's we're gonna learn how much this
treatment effect infectivity and if
treatment dramatically affects
infectivity and hospitalization this
becomes the flu okay and that might be
hydrochloric wine would be hard rising
clerk
it's a hydroxy a lot of money right but
people are my peers are using it like
crazy their hands enthusiasm for it so
they think they're doing something now
whether the data bears that I will see
your boy has a stop double yeah my buddy
no hoarding I have a friend who's a
physician on the front lines at UCLA he
just he just got go ahead he just came
down a lot of health care he's on
elevators cause he taking it he's not
he's doing another thing another
antiviral yeah there's some really good
intimate III predict this really what's
probably gonna work as some sort of
combo antivirals much like with HIV yeah
something like that weights heavy they I
mean for you and I grown up with I was
deeper than I so that's what I work
alongside of voci I was I was putting
watching the really really really I was
I remember being in New York people
don't realize when you're my age
certainly yeah you were there he was and
all my friends all the theater people
all the people arsenite yeah I watch
them die slowly and so terribly if they
would lose their mind and they would
starve to death it's really really so
bad for depressing but fascinating to
talk to him about like like 79 to 85
dude you about being like when they were
still calling it grids right yeah chorus
terrified of AIDS yeah we just started
calling she's like it was foul to you
that got me to go on the radio oh he was
going we're gonna have 10 million damn
three years time we're gonna gotta gotta
get educated kids you and so I was like
okay what can I do it so I had that in
my
constantly and when I had the
opportunity to go on the radio I was
like Jesus Christ no one's talking to
young people about this I can't believe
I got to do this and then Magic Johnson
came along 93 and said hold my aids and
then well and it also became it was a
disease that ultimately did discriminate
which was hard for the right and we did
and we were part I was part of the media
that said no no no no no because we were
fearful and I'm hoping that dr. found
she's overstating this one too mm-hmm
because we I was part of the course that
overstated we were saying we my
recollection is correct we were saying
ten million three years ten million
three years we ended up with 175,000 it
was awful I think but I think when they
overestimate things I think they almost
have to and the media I'll give them
this credit where they put this panic in
people because if you don't make it so
serious
most the average American is not gonna
listen it was it's thready call my
friend because I can't fathom that yeah
and so I was part of that chorus and I
know we were off by a factor of 100 so
I'm hopeful were far off by a factor of
10 and they did things we did things
then much like we're doing things there
are those guys and we appreciate it
you're a special dude man all right yeah
we love you guys man person yeah he's
the best
I miss you guys I know we're always
always gonna start knocking on your door
your podcast is rockin too right you can
do it you have to all kind of stuff but
I do a thing called after dark that's
real popular right now your mom's house
sigur rós blog platform and then I'm
doing a streaming show every day at dr.
Drew calm where I just make sense of all
this data and all this crap it's called
rock it side side talked about dose of
dr. Drew at dr. Drew calm yeah one of
the reasons I reached out because my
brother is he's on he sends me all these
faxes you got to get dr. Drew on because
there's so much negativity out there
right now more he's more right and try
to make sense of it make sense yeah and
calm everybody down so Jay was really
God you Dalia doctor I was so psyched to
have you on my sister was so psyched
because she's always sending me stuff by
where she lived the ladies love Luka
like to look yeah the ladies love Drew
well we love you guys things coming in
man thank you guys really
you miss you guys till it bites me like
you're some longtime very easy so do it
or next time any to always love you guys
things coming in thank you guys